NORTH LAWN TODAY.
>> Dana: HE IS HARD TO MISS HE
IS SO TALL.
TED CRUZ, GOOD TO HAVE YOU, SIR.
KAMALA HARRIS’S APPOINTMENT TO
TAKE OVER THE BORDER, LEADER
MCCARTHY ON THE SENATE SIDE
SAID SHE IS THE POINT PERSON
FOR THE BORDER CRISIS AND THEN
SENATOR HARRIS COMPARED ICE TO
THE K.K.K., INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO REDUCE DETENTION
BEDS AND SAID HOLDING KIDS OVER
72 HOURS WAS INHUMANE.
DOES SHE STAND BY THAT?
I WOULD ASK YOU, SHOULD SHE BE
GIVEN A CHANCE TO DO THIS AND
SEE HOW SHE DOES?
>> I HAVE TO SAY MY REACTION TO
THAT APPOINTMENT IS WOW, JOE
BIDEN REALLY DOESN’T LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS.
THIS BORDER CRISIS IS THE
BIGGEST POLITICAL MESS JOE
BIDEN HAS.
IT THREATENS TO DERAIL THE
ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT DOES HE DO?
LOOKS TO HIS VICE PRESIDENT AND
SAYS YOU TAKE IT.
IT IS YOUR PROBLEM NOW.
LISTEN, UNFORTUNATELY SHE IS
NOTING TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS.
WHY?
THEY CREATED THIS CRISIS AND
THEY DID IT BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLITICAL PARTISAN COMMITMENTS
THAT THEY CAN’T BACK AWAY FROM.
WHY ARE WE HAVING THIS CRISIS
AT THE BORDER?
WHEN JOE BIDEN GOT ELECTED THE
FIRST THING HE DID WAS STOP
CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER
WALL, REINSTITUTED CATCH AND
RELEASE.
THE FAILED POLICY.
NOW WHEN WE DETAIN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WE LET THEM GO, GIVE
THEM A COURT DATE SOMETIME IN
THE FUTURE AND MANY NEVER SHOW
UP.
AND HE ENDED THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY, THIS INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL FOREIGN POLICY
ACCOMPLISHMENT WHERE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED WITH
MEXICO THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA WOULD
REMAIN IN MEXICO WHILE THEIR
ASYLUM PROCEEDINGS WERE MOVING
FORWARD.
THEY ALL PRODUCED REAL SUCCESS.
BUT BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
CAMPAIGN ON SAYING ICE IS EVIL.
SECURING THE BORDER IS WRONG.
THE DEMOCRATS SUPPORT OPEN
BORDERS.
KAMALA HARRIS DOESN’T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO OTHER THAN GO
DOWN THERE AND LET EVERYBODY GO.
THAT’S THE ONLY OPTION THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE POLITICAL
PROMISES SHE HAS MADE.
I’LL TELL YOU REPRESENTING THE
STATE OF TEXAS WE’RE SEEING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BEING
RELEASED IN HARLINGEN, TEXAS.
THEY’RE TESTING POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19 AT A SEVEN TIMES
HIGHER RATE THAN THE U.S.
POPULATION.
IT IS A HUMANITARIAN, PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SECURITY CRISIS.
>> Bill: YOU ARE GOING THERE
TOMORROW WITH SENATOR CORNYN.
WHEN DO YOU THINK KAMALA HARRIS
GOES OR PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
THEY ASKED KAMALA A FEW DAYS
AGO IF SHE WAS GOING AND SHE
LAUGHED AT THAT QUESTION.
TONIGHT I’M HEADED TO THE
BORDER AND BRINGING 18 SENATORS.
I’M BRINGING 18 SENATORS TO GO
DOWN TO THE BORDER.
WE ARE GOING TO THE FACILITIES
AND MEETING WITH BORDER PATROL
AND THE BORDER PATROL UNION WHO
I KNOW VERY WELL.
WE’LL INSPECT THOSE FACILITIES
AND SEE THEM DIRECTLY.
I’LL TELL YOU, WE INVITED FOX
NEWS TO EMBED WITH US AND ABC
NEWS TO EMBED WITH US.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
SAID HELL NO, THEY WILL NOT
ALLOW REPORTERS ANYWHERE NEAR.
THEY ARE BLOCKING WHAT 18
SENATORS SHOW UP, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING NO
REPORTER CAN SHOW UP BECAUSE --
THIS IS THEIR ARGUMENT AND IT
IS LAUGHABLE.
THEY SAY THAT REPORTERS --
THERE IS TOO BIG A RISK OF
COVID.
IF THERE IS A CAMERAMAN,
SUDDENLY IT IS A COVID CRISIS.
NEVER MIND THE DONNA FACILITY
THAT THEY WON’T ALLOW REPORTERS
INTO.
THE DONNA FACILITY’S CAPACITY
IS 250 PEOPLE.
IT CURRENTLY HAS NEARLY 4,000
PEOPLE IN IT.
THAT’S 1,500% IN EXCESS OF ITS
CAPACITY.
THERE IS A REASON THEY DON’T
WANT REPORTERS IN THERE.
IT IS NOT COVID.
THE REASON THEY DON’T WANT
REPORTERS IN THERE IS BECAUSE
THEY DON’T WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO REALIZE THE ABSOLUTE
TRAIN WRECK OF A POLICY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
IMPLEMENTED.
>> Bill: YOU CAN LET THEM KNOW.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING FOR A YEAR
NON-STOP.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING
HAPPENING A BIG DEAL YESTERDAY.
HR1, THE BILL THAT THE
DEMOCRATS PASSED IN THE HOUSE
BASICALLY COMPLETELY CHANGE
VOTING RIETSZ IN AMERICA, THERE
WAS A HEARING ON IT YESTERDAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR AMERICANS
TO KNOW ABOUT THAT BILL?
>> I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
SINGLE MOST DANGEROUS BILL
BEING CONSIDERED BY CONGRESS
RIGHT NOW.
IT IS THE CORRUPT POLITICIANS
ACT.
IT DESIGNED TO ENTRENCH CORRUPT
POLITICIANS IN OFFICE, KEEP
DEMOCRATS IN POWER FOR 100
YEARS.
IT HAS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TAKE OVER ALL ELECTIONS.
IT REPEALS VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
COMMON SENSE STATE INTEGRITY
LAWS FOR ELECTION INTEGRITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, 29 STATES HAVE
VOTER I.D. LAWS INCLUDING TEXAS.
THE CORRUPT POLITICIANS ACT
REPEALS EVERY ONE OF THEM SAYS
IT’S ILLEGAL TO REQUIRE
IDENTIFICATION TO VOTE.
THE CORRUPT POLITICIAN ACT ALSO
MANDATES UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN
VOTING EVERYWHERE FOR NO REASON
WHATSOEVER AND MANDATES BALLOT
HARVESTING.
31 STATES HAVE MADE ILLEGAL.
PAID POLITICAL OPERATIVES THAT
GO TO A NURSING HOME AND
COLLECT HUNDREDS OF BALLOTS.
IT IS THE SINGLE MOST LIKELY
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR VOTER FRAUD
THAWS THOSE PAID OPERATIVES CAN
GO TO VULNERABLE SENIORS IN
NURSING HOMES WHO MAY NOT BE IN
A CONDITION TO MAKE CHOICES.
IF THE SENIORS VOTE IN A WAY
THEY DON’T LIKE THEY CAN THROW
THEIR BALLOT AWAY.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO EXPAND
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR FRAUD
AND I’LL TELL YOU MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY THAN THAT.
IT AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERS
ANYONE WHO INTERACTS WITH THE
GOVERNMENT.
WHO GETS A WELFARE CHECK,
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK, DRIVER’S
LICENSE, GOES TO A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT WILL
RESULT IN MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BEING REGISTERED TO
VOTE AND THAT IS THEIR
OBJECTIVE IS TO GET MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO VOTE AND
ALSO STRIKES DOWN ALL THE STATE
LAWS LIMITING FELONS AND
CRIMINALS FROM VOTING.
THIS LAW MANDATES THAT WHEN
ANYONE LEAVES PRISON THEY CAN
IMMEDIATELY VOTE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DECIDED WHAT
AMERICA NEEDS THE MORE
MURDERERS, RAPISTS AND CHILD
MOLESTERS VOTING AND MILLIONS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
CRIMINALS VOTING IS GOING TO
BENEFIT DEMOCRATS AND KEEP THEM
IN POWER.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
>> Bill: QUICKLY I WANT TO PLAY
A CLIP FROM YOU YESTERDAY ON
THE HILL.
YOU CAME OUT TO TALK TO
REPORTERS AND THIS EXCHANGE
WENT THE FOLLOWING WAY.
>> COULD YOU PLEASE PUT YOUR
MASK ON?
>> WHEN I’M TALKING TO THE TV
CAMERA I’M NOT WEARING A MAX.
WE’VE ALL BEEN IMMUNIZED.
YOU ARE WELCOME TO STEP AWAY IF
YOU LIKE.
THE WHOLE POINT OF A VACCINE,
CDC GUIDANCE IS WHAT WE’RE
FOLLOWING.
>> Bill: WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
THAT WE DID NOT SEE ON CAMERA?
>> THAT PARTICULAR CAMERAMAN
WENT AND LEFT AND HE DECIDED HE
DIDN’T WANT TO BE AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
HE IS WELCOME TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE.
AT SOME POINT IT IS A LITTLE
SILLY.
I’VE GOT TO SAY IF YOU TURN ON
THE TV ON ANY GIVEN DAY AND
WATCH, SAY, THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS CONFERENCE WITH JEN PSAKI.
SHE HASN’T WORN A MASK AND YOU
DIDN’T SEE REPORTERS THROWING A
FIT AND RUNNING SCREAMING OUT
OF THE ROOM.
IT IS PARTICULARLY ABSURD WHEN
EVERY SENATOR STANDING THERE
HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
AT SOME POINT IT BECOMES A
THEATER.
I’M NOT SOMEONE WHO SAYS NEVER
WEAR A MASK.
USE COMMON SENSE PRECAUTIONS.
PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN PRETTY CRAZY
ABOUT THIS STUFF.